30 miles north of detroit lies the
township of macomb county home to
giuseppe's its owners joe borgia and his
wife kathy have owned several successful
italian restaurants in the span of 25
years
after retiring they decided to open
giuseppe's with the dream of passing it
down to their son sam i opened it with
the expectations that we would put sam
on his feet and joe and i could just go
to florida or wherever but it just
hasn't worked out that way sam basically
said dad i'm going to step up to the
plate i want to work day and night you
and mom can come a little bit at a time
but when they started working 20 hours a
week to me it was like another empty
promise
you want to go get your son because
every time we i try to explain he's got
to walk away sam
did you walk off the line
no it's a nightmare for two reasons the
lack of customers
and the hell that goes out in the
kitchen
you're serving frozen [ __ ] salmon i
mean no matter what you do you can boil
it in grease no it's still gonna be gone
that's probably wrong you proved me
wrong then
i'm not supposed to have no input i'm
not supposed to be able to change
anything usually people roast them on
the barbecue no that's the way you do it
i'm just supposed to basically be a
shadow and somebody that he can just say
it's your fault okay dan whatever you
say i'm brian i'm a truck driver but i
chef here part time right here joe i've
known joe for forever he's getting up
there a little bit in years and he's
just he's getting tired and i don't
think that his son is stepping up to the
plate
you don't have to be back there i'm not
i just have pushed him in too many hours
they're not pushing you you're pushing
you i'm a diabetic
some days i don't feel like coming in
some days i can't even roll out of bed
but i have to be here that's my
responsibility
my sugar is low i'm [ __ ] up here i
cooked that i got it my dance house is
not good by any standards and it's the
most heartbreaking thing to see i just
want my family to be healthy and happy
everything else doesn't matter if
anybody can help our family it would
probably be chef ramsey
[Music]
i'm here to work with a family in a
restaurant that's in crisis the
kitchen's run by father and son and
they're constantly at each other's
throat the mother's torn between them
both she's actually here to pick me up
wow he's got a smile let's good that's a
good sign
i was excited and nervous but i knew
once he was here everything was going to
be fine nice to see my daddy
and thank you so much for coming to put
me up
now the restaurant's run by joe your
husband my husband joe giuseppe and
joe's the head chef and sansa sous chef
exactly is some taken over from joe or
well that was the plan but it's not
happening and i'm sure sam's a little
disappointed he's 28 he must be ready
for it now surely he's about the
maturity of about a 23 year old right
he's not ready
and the russian's only going for two
years yeah and i'm in debt big time i
got my house in foreclosure i owe about
150 thousand dollars outside of that
outside am i losing the house if i can
sleep anywhere but the business that's
everything i have and at my age i can't
start over again
how does um joe feel about this he's
miserable inside damn if this place
fails i don't even know if we'll be
together anymore
this is it this is it this is my little
play hope you brought your magic wand
excellent thank you you're welcome
i think chef ramsay may be overwhelmed
this time it's not just as simple as a
menu change or firing somebody i think
it's a little more complex and i think
this is where you'll be okay great
that palomino sauce sam i know you don't
want to listen to me yeah i do exactly
how you say put way too much white wine
on it and that's why you're getting the
baroness told me to put the white wine
with joe overseeing the kitchen sam will
be cooking a menu designed by his father
for chef ramsay i think chef ramsay's
gonna come in here order a few things
and he's gonna say they're horrible
welcome to the sepi's tutorial please
allow my family and i to introduce you
to the essence of italy
the old world family recipes and cozy
atmosphere
[Music]
this place has only been open for two
years it looks like something from the
1970s
hello hi i'm john nice to meet you and
you're one of the servers obviously i am
one of the servers what would you
recommend my darling i would recommend
the eggplant rollatini that's our house
specialty okay great and um
i'll start off with the potato skins and
the octopus salad okay and i'll keep
hold of the menu because i'm you know
i'm going to read on okay thank you so
much you're welcome
essence obviously
my ass
what do we get we need octopus salad
yeah potato skins
okay
that's first and i'll guide you through
when i saw chef ramsey ordered i would
say every part of me wanted to say we're
out of it can you please take the salad
out of the window please but how would
that look
octopus salad that was quick
thank you my dog enjoy thank you
jesus
[Music]
got the octopus like rubber
[Music]
excuse me
jesus christ
it's like a mouthful of hubbub
it should be done in a frying pan very
slowly oh yeah i got it dad let me get
this potato skin
is that normally that chewy that old
pistol
i think it is i've heard people say that
before would you be my guest just decide
to be your guest please
very tough
but i tasted it i'm like oh my gosh we
serve this [ __ ] i mean basically that's
what it was that's what it tasted like
horrible octopus is chewy horrible
and how are the potato skins the cheese
is um
hideous not good would you like to try
one no i don't i've had enough
how are we doing guys octopus is [ __ ]
that is chewy these are hideous too
cheese is disgusting
oh boy
i always brag about how good my food is
and i'm good my restaurant is and if
they don't step up to the plate i am
going to cook every individual dinner in
this restaurant pretty much a little bit
[Music]
hey clint rolantini thanks son you're
welcome thank you
i i think it's too much wine i mean
that's my personal thing it's too much
wine i you know i make a new one
can't really identify any flavors
because it's just absolutely piping hot
almost like it's been nuked in the
microwave for three minutes i can cook
every dish that he had and i guarantee
he was going to love every one of them
one that's got on him
and why aren't you back here a lot
because maybe they should try you out
see you know what's going on honestly
sounds like there's a war going on it's
incredible this many [ __ ] complaints
in two [ __ ] years
relax my ass
god damn it
[Music]
two [ __ ] ears
after sensing gordon's disappointment
with lunch the family regroups in the
kitchen we got to stop being
the mother the husband the son
family is one thing we are in the
business yeah and if you think that it's
that responsibility be the chef you
better be the god damn best [ __ ] chef
on the side of mississippi i want to be
the best chef on the other side it's
we're in michigan
but i want you to be my father too
you know i just want to grab my dad and
give him a hug and say look it's going
to be all right you just gotta trust in
me a little bit now it's time for joe
sam and sous chef brian to hear the cold
hard truth from chef ramsay hello sir
how are you nice to meet you you said on
the back of the menu step into
giuseppe's and i'm gonna take you
through a romantic authentic restaurant
in italy i like the passion but the
palettes [ __ ]
that eggplant bland milky spongy and
then piping hot in the middle like it
had been blasted in the microwave it was
it was yeah
so you don't bake them fresh no
chef we got probably 3 000 respond that
we did this question here and we didn't
get one negative thing about the food so
where the [ __ ] are they then
i don't know you don't need
questionnaires they don't ring you up
say by the way i'm not coming back they
just don't come back they vote with
their feet
why are we serving potato skins do i
want to come to an authentic italian
restaurant with potato skins absolutely
not
a lot of people come here with their
kids and their kids don't want to die
i've lived in italy i've seen the
italian families the way they eat
together they don't serve [ __ ]
children in italy potato skins with
plastic cheese i'm going to show you
there's no [ __ ] reason to have potato
skins on an italian menu
joe i'm not asking for excuses i'm here
to help yeah but everything i'm saying
all you're doing is firing me [ __ ]
excuses don't [ __ ] me and i won't
[ __ ] you do you understand yeah
i got told in the car are the pressures
facing this place
but i can see why we're in the ship the
food's crap guys i thought i had a job
to do but now it's just become ten times
[ __ ] bigger that's true i'll see you
later on this afternoon get some rest
thank you sir
[Applause]
just that he may have been born in italy
but he's certainly not delivering
italian authentic cuisine here in
michigan he may say on the back of the
menu but he's not delivering flavor
that's for sure
[Music]
before gordon can formulate his plan to
turn around the restaurant he wants to
see a dinner service and the staff in
action how are you today good how are
you hi how are you my name is carol
[Music]
zack come off at me
looks like a [ __ ] or two
[Music]
hi how are you
three yeah not a problem
hi who are you is everything okay here
so far good
you ready honey oh yeah i would like to
add meat sauce meat sauce thank you dude
thank you
[Music]
iron hole baby and here we go
what's up everyone's gonna be uh order
roast potato how can they be raised
protectors in the microwave that's the
program here so it just happy once has
he lost his [ __ ] marbles my dad feels
like he just needs to push the food out
real fast you know he wants to smell
cheese in the microwave but you can't
take shortcuts like that
it's horrible you know food comes out
quick is that normal really quick too
quick i think then what would you like
i'll have the uh ravioli florentine
thank you sometimes sailors or soups and
then their main entree comes all at once
[Music]
you guys want to do the wings as well
enjoy okay i always call it fast food
italian hospital yeah yeah
you're not wrong man the sauce is warm
but the inside it needs to be warmed up
okay honey
hey brian can you please warm this for
me yep
more crap
don't want it don't want to redo that
was a ravioli with alfredo the pillows
are hard well we have so much problem
with that i i don't get it brian does
the inside's a little bit on the cool
side okay can i put it in the microwave
unbelievable two things i can definitely
confirm the first thing is they're fast
unfortunately two passes are on good the
second thing is when they're fast
they're sloppy over 12 dishes have come
back and this place is about to explode
unbelievable
is everything okay tonight um i don't
know if i like this one do you want
something else it's a little bit too
lemony i'll be right back excuse me i'm
gonna have a reorder here a little too
lemony maybe we should stick to one
goddamn recipe maybe we should put your
ingredients on a little bit olive oil
what just straight olive oil you want
like a caramelity mix
you put your salt and pepper and garlic
in here yeah coming through i got it i
was trying to ask you what you wanted
hey if i said calamari max you should
know what i mean i didn't hear calamari
mix that's what i said
to see my father not trust me was just
getting downright frustrated i don't
know what else to show my violin
this is supposed to be black and it
wasn't black and that's all fat you need
a new steak
what'd they say i need a no did you want
another steak yes okay medium rare
blackened tim you know what blackened
means dad i put it on a flat top i put
the cajun seasoning on i put it on there
and i cook both sides medium wear black
and is that what blackened is i do need
another steak medium rare blackened okay
very black and very spicy whatever
where's the kitchen spice i got it over
here sam has like a new puppy that you
have to constantly pay attention to this
is a joke he's now ready to run their
business why don't we ever add thousand
this line there's a towel right there i
won't even wipe my ass with that there's
towels right there it's all down here
joe
did not like
what the hell how'd that steak on that
redo you want me to cook it doesn't come
out of my ass okay all right i hope it
doesn't come out of your ass
don't touch your steak
what the hell sam get you us out of
there
let's try to make them happy
[Music]
joe
did not like after multiple dishes are
returned joe kicks sam out of the
kitchen okay sam get you us out of there
and takes matters into his own hands
you want to make somebody happy and that
somebody happens to be your
father you want to make him proud of you
you want to make him believe in you but
i don't know how to do that
after 28 years i'm still trying
[Music]
now i'm really seriously starting to
understand what it's like behind the
scenes in the kitchen you've got brian
there and sam cooking fine but too far
so they're doing good all of a sudden
joe walks in marks his orders and then
disappears but when he walks in they all
stand to attention and he talks them
like dirt unfortunately that dirt's his
son
sad
right
that was tough
we've got ourselves in a real horrible
rut
cooking in that kitchen because it's
just
slamming food
i've never seen so much food go in a
microwave
in all my life
it's like no one's striving to be better
you tell me how you feel about the
frozen food
i hate it
i'm embarrassed to say it's my food
why don't you tell dad
that you want to cook fresh
dad i want to cook fresh
i want to cook fresh
[Music]
is sam a good chef
[Music]
he
he likes to cook
i don't want my children insulted
whether it's true or not it cuts me
and only a mother would understand that
and what's his weaknesses
you're not committed you put 25 hours a
week i used to work that with my when i
have my first restaurant one day why
haven't you been committed my father
doesn't really talk to me that much and
you know i
i feel that you sometimes you hate me no
i don't want to be i don't talk to you
because you don't put enough time here
to get involved you wish you fire in
your belly
i mean what can you show me the same set
of balls that i had and just go up there
and try to make something out of it i've
been [ __ ] doing that [ __ ] since i was
[ __ ] 13 nice to you you don't see me
you don't see me see what sam private
scrubbing floor is nice here i've been
wanting you to [ __ ] notice me for a
while i don't know how many times you
looked at me and said hey
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] good job not once this
won't tell me about that every year
you're not here long enough to do that
sam i'm not long enough for you to say
good [ __ ] job one time come on i
don't know what else to say
no matter what there's always a
complaint
i have not served him anything without
him saying it's not done right
it hurts i mean still to this day i'm
almost 30 years old and that stupid [ __ ]
hurts we've got our cards out on the
table now i want to see the passion i
want to see that little bit of flame
relit the lights back on
[Music]
in the morning gordon wants to focus his
attention on joe before the customer's
coming let's have two minutes together
not his battles with his son but his
battle with a crippling disease
how does it affect you that level of
diabetes diabetes is the worst
disease you can have
i got pain in my legs every day and you
have a
proper medical insurance no i don't oh
come on i don't okay we can't afford
that i cut it off
you know i've been without insurance for
you know since we opened this restaurant
god's sake
you know rest is the first thing you
need you can't be here seven days a week
i built this restaurant i've been
putting in
70 hours a week
i would like my son to run this
restaurant that me
kick back but sam doesn't follow through
and now i'm stuck with this thing on my
shoulder and i'm keeping digging until i
dig myself out you can't be a [ __ ]
master you know hey you've got to look
after yourself
you know you keep me posted on how you
feel it yeah okay thank you chad thank
you
before gordon can turn around giuseppe's
i want to turn up a notch he needs to
test sam's abilities i want to cook off
and reignite joe's passion
both of you cook something unique
anything you want the front of house
stuff i'm gonna taste they won't know
who's cooked what but what they will
know is which dish is the best because
that dish tonight is going on as a
special ready let's go
chef ramsay said that we were gonna have
the cookoff i kind of just wanted to do
something simple but bold and hopefully
impress chef ramsay and impress my
father on top of it
everything hand bought freshly made
pasta fresh lasagna fresh salmon
asparagus double pork chops garlic basil
blow me away okay
[Music]
i saw the salmon just caught out of the
water maybe two hours ago i had to go
for the salmon i love it
i used steak general cup pork chop and i
sear some scallops with some pachera
with some italian sausage and provolone
cheese okay let's go
[Music]
okay all right two dishes first one's a
broiled salmon with asparagus coated an
egg finished with provolone cheese and
the salmon has been char broiled
next to that we've got a pork chop
stuffed served on cyber grilled potatoes
and gratinated with provolone cheese
take a taste and then pass it down yeah
i was confident in my dish because i
always cook with a little flavor a
little flavor to it
[Music]
okay
we're gonna start with uh mum
out of both dishes which one would you
choose as a special i would take the
pork chop put it with the potatoes not
the pasta with the asparagus
so bitter both that's a fair answer
diplomat
okay brian out of both dishes which one
would you choose the uh pork chop pork
chop yes
right darling which one would you choose
definitely the pork chop and the
mushrooms okay
treat it with the pork chop
tony
out of both dishes which one would you
choose um
i would have to say there's salmon
salmon
[Music]
okay dawn
if i was just looking at the menu and
hadn't tasted them
i'd probably go with the salmon
but after tasting it i'd go with a pork
chop
right well done well thank you yeah
really well done huh
sure i was a little disappointed i'm not
gonna lie but at the same time i want
him to be better than me because i need
someone to look up to i need a mentor in
my life
my choice out of both those dishes
they're both good enough to go on this
menu tonight yes that's what's going to
happen
two specials congratulations good dish
i wish he would have wanted to tell you
the truth you know which is that she
looked really good tonight you're gonna
be cooking your father's special make
sure you know the dish inside out you
got it
i'm real fired up not only because we're
putting a new item out there that
everybody's gonna taste but me and my
father are gonna work together on each
other's dishes and i know they're gonna
be excellent
with everyone feeling good about
tonight's specials gordon begins to work
on another problem of this restaurant
the lack of communication between joe
sam and kathy i'm here to help
but it's it's
every hour is changing because i've
never ever quite come across such a
difficult
restaurant situation in all my life
because the restaurant's one thing but
the biggest problem is the family and
what i want you to do is i want you to
write a letter
and say in that letter what you really
want to say to them both
write that letter for me please
don't show any of them yet
[Music]
my objective tonight is to push the
specials you've got one made by the
father and one from the up and coming
son want to make sure that you sell them
with joe momentarily out of the kitchen
gordon sees a chance to speak with sam i
will just give you two minutes to uh
drew yeah
tonight when you get out of here you get
home i want you to tell me in a letter
to your father yeah what you really
feel about him what kind of figure that
guy is in your life
yeah i want you to put it on paper for
me discreetly and i mean discreetly
[Music]
hi how are you good thank you first
customers to hear you here we go yeah
booth over here okay we're gonna put the
pork okay and the scallop i'm trying um
i am going to try the salmon
as well thank you okay here we go you're
gonna be expediting in and out and
you're on the line yeah yeah yeah good
good man
so it's gonna be two pork giuseppe okay
two pork chickens all right let's show
them what we're made of olive oil
very nice what a breath of fresh air
every dish like that yes yes sir salmon
enjoy your meal do seven supports you
got it
mmm i really like the pork chop don't
overcook this ham it's just
once again joe can't give up control of
the kitchen it's well done instead of
expediting and making sure orders are
filled quickly he's at the stove cooking
sam's dishes it took 25 minutes for a
calamari
joe
are you expediting no not really
i can't read without my glasses your
glasses around your neck
[ __ ] it up this is his heart this is his
place but he's got to learn that he
can't always be in the middle of the
action i can't do it anymore man what's
wrong brother
he's going to kill himself sugar is low
i'm [ __ ] up joe expedite let sound
cook jesus christ want to switch i'll
i'll dress them up well i can see
chef ramsay wanted joe to expedite but
that's italian in him never let go never
give up never surrender help me pull him
off right because that's the only way i
mean literally we got to pull him on how
did you get my flat stove he's
magnetized there
is that a steak
it's well done
i don't like that steak guy i don't like
it it's well done tam it looks like [ __ ]
time yeah kick him up fat i'm sorry dude
but your [ __ ] sugar's up you gotta
get up
thank you
[Applause]
with joe finally off the line if that
kid we don't let him stand and fail a
few times he's never going to stand up
sam and brian regain control of the
kitchen that my friend there you go
tommy and finish the service very good
and while the staff was cleaning up two
seconds gordon cornered joe
is it your wish
that one day sam takes over
yeah
i want you to go home and just write a
short letter how you feel about him what
he means to you and what you want him to
be one day i want you to talk from the
heart
and
you've got to keep it between you and i
i will i will
[Music]
even though the specials were a big
success this restaurant still has a long
way to go before it's ready for relaunch
tonight wasn't good enough for this
restaurant
if we're gonna establish any form of
longevity i know we can all do better
tomorrow we are going to do better we're
going to relaunch and market this place
so you
get yourself off to bed
yeah so you're going to work for a
change i mean
[Laughter]
you're such a rottweiler
okay good night
immediately after the family and staff
left chef ramsay's team went into high
gear working through the night to
transform giuseppe's into a contemporary
italian eatery
what a beautiful morning for a relaunch
how are we good when i first arrived the
restaurant was dated and it's almost
like you'd opened a dated restaurant
this is what you call a modern
contemporary italian are you ready to
see the new giuseppe's yeah yes good
let's go let's go let's go
come through
look at this
[Music]
is it beautiful
huh
it was claustrophobic now it's a modern
contemporary italian restaurant i just
couldn't believe that something like
this could be done and it just the time
that i slept
i'm totally took him back by us it's
like a different place new bastards new
drapes
nice new chairs
oh my god
oh my god he's holding sammy he's just
born
when i saw my father look at the
pictures of me and him when i was a
little boy
you know when i saw a tear come to his
eyes i almost lost it you feel like
you're stepping inside something
historic now it's modern yes i love it
run by an amazing family joe i just i
don't know how you do stuff like that
you deserve it my man come here
and you're just doing it huh
is it lovely it's beautiful isn't it
beautiful
huh i'm so happy because
now we have a real chance it's a new
beginning this is beautiful
something even more important now
marketing
in order to re-launch this restaurant
we're gonna host the first ever
giuseppe's bowl-a-thon with the american
diabetes association yes
i'm overwhelmed
you know bolton for diabetes which i
lost my brother and
so
it's it's it's a big thing
for diabetes it took your brother it
took your mother that's not taking my
taking you
hi guys
thank you so much for coming and thank
you so much for being part of our first
ever giuseppe's
bowl-a-thon were greeted by a warm crowd
cheering for us like we were some
celebrity you guys hungry
there you go
it was great to see my father passing
out soups and talking to the customers
and getting them all excited about our
restaurant thank you so much thank you
appreciate it
i have no words for this but i'm glad
that you guys are here and uh help
spread the word about diabetes we're
going to fight it and without the real
people we're gonna do it
[Music]
after the success of the first ever
giuseppe's bowl-a-thon chef ramsay and
the staff returned to the restaurant to
prepare for the relaunch the condensed
menu it's fresher it's quicker it's
smaller and more importantly it's ten
times more exciting the classic soups
pasta violi minnesota soup that's the
heartbeat of the russians okay the
chicken parmesan look at that it's a new
way modern and something complete when
chef ramsey presented our new menu and i
saw that all the old [ __ ] was off i
was excited we're at 2008 now and here's
the menu to prove it more importantly if
this russian's got chance of survival
we've got to communicate and stick
together tonight right now i'm so
excited i feel like i'm 18 years old
again
for tonight's dinner service chef ramsay
has assigned sam to run the line and joe
to expedite we've been given every
opportunity now it's time for me to step
up to the plate and knock it out of the
park
hello
welcome to the new giuseppe's tractoria
[Music]
are you ready to order fettuccine
kavanaugh
seafood planter one of them
i'm ready to rock and roll
this is a very very important night it's
not just about the relaunch of deceptis
it's their transition that's what's got
to take place tonight will sam step up
to the mark and can joe let go and give
sam the confidence to run this place
time will
tell all right i got three marcelo's
coming right now i need them baby only
30 minutes into service medium well it's
coming right after and stubborn joe is
on the line cooking again yeah do you
want to get off the line we got it i got
three marcelo's coming on a fly i need
him sammy dad get off the line go
marcela coming hard
kid it's not gonna be you on the line
you understand my father wasn't letting
go he doesn't need to be back there
right in the hatchet if anything he's
making things more complicated priority
chicken marsala what's wrong it's wrong
oh [ __ ] it sam yes not now buddy i've
got pink chicken okay come on come on
come on slow it down i'd rather wait an
extra five minutes and send out [ __ ]
pink chicken yes sir take your time
i'm kind of having a problem with the
lasagna and ricotta's cool hey
hey you guys good fam
they need this cook more all right they
said it's cold yes ma'am don't rush it
we're not rushing yeah we are we're
going right back
this grill sucks yeah do you want to get
off the line this thing is awful sam dan
that's hard brother i've made the best
things in the world off of it i was
again seeing the same thing my dad
getting worn out getting angry dad go we
got it if we can't handle it then we
shouldn't be here
and it was really starting to get to me
joe
joe two seconds yeah they have to learn
to do it without you yeah take 10
minutes out get some fresh air please
hey they're fine get out please
they have to learn all right i got this
[ __ ] corrected i just got to get a field
mario working okay please do it man come
on send it man let's go go go
get
out
[ __ ] how
if i was rich
sure the hell wouldn't be here well i'd
still be here
there
yeah hey
steve we got tamara on this bread sit
down i've got the bread
[ __ ] hell that guy's unbelievable
[Music]
unbelievable this guy is incredible he
had to leave the line he's down and out
and he's beat so they've got to step up
the mark and it's now or never for those
guys they've got to do it for joe the
restaurant and more importantly for
themselves come on
there you are thank you you're welcome
that table was here half an hour after
us enjoy we still haven't received our
food yet honey it's coming how are we
doing here sammy coming man guy can i
plate this look at it i'm not plating it
i'm not playing i'm plating it okay
great you want a goddamn award
i heard all the noise in the kitchen i
mean it's a zoo back there if they're
screwing around it's hard to run a
smooth chip i do apologize for the delay
okay we got a seafood platter there you
go dear please enjoy your food hey yeah
quality up here where's quality right
here yes quality there thank you
unfortunately brian's goofing off is
causing sam to lose his focus you want
quality i got you quality huh
and the customers are feeling the
offense
i apologize that's ridiculous
can you please reorder this for me
what's the matter with this the insides
are on the court side come on
okay
brian sam come here a minute from behind
the line sounds like we're [ __ ]
around true's coming back raw all i want
to do is cut the [ __ ] around and just
concentrate a little bit because if you
concentrate [ __ ] won't come back raw we
waited an hour for our food now i'm
sitting here 20 minutes waiting for a
raw fish just quit the [ __ ] around
you'll see a difference in the standard
come on guys i know we can do better
you're [ __ ] here we can do better
come on they just concentrate
yeah chefs
screw that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're stung cold and rolling you know
whose fault all this is tonight it's his
the people are done eating and she
hasn't got her dick i haven't even
gotten my food out i want to leave all
right
you know who i blame i blame all this on
you
it's not difficult so stop making
[ __ ] pathetic excuses
here we got chef ramsay giving us a hand
and now you're gonna turn around and
basically spit in his face and say it's
your fault that i suck that's horrible i
feel sorry for the man
honey it's coming we don't even want it
yeah hold on good i'm just gonna slow
down stop being a [ __ ] goofball
throwing food out there good great
nothing complicated outstanding good man
good man
v6 is ready to walk we got a table
walking let's go guys get back in your
[ __ ] truck right coming to me looking
for excuses excuse me i got no excuses
you just said you blame me in the [ __ ]
oh yeah when i first arrived that's cool
thanks jeff
huh what a [ __ ] idiot
folks being this together right
i would never come back here again
[ __ ] cement mixer you guys are paying
the ass where's brian
[Music]
in this hugely important dinner service
hey three marcelo's coming on a fly i
need them sammy dishes started to come
back sam yeah i've got pink chicken pull
it together come on
and when chef ramsay tried to restore
order quit the [ __ ] around you'll see
a difference in the standard brian
couldn't handle the criticism you know
who i blame i blame all this on you get
back in your [ __ ] truck right coming
to me looking for excuses thanks chefs
and packed it in it's hosting this
together right what a [ __ ] idiot
guy's a pain in the ass
leaving a father and son to rely on each
other to save this restaurant come on
i'm not giving up i'm not [ __ ] giving
up all right
yo marsala is it already marcelo is
coming right now okay i think you're the
sauce okay i got a shrimp scampi coming
on a fly uh salmon right after you got
it we got this all right i couldn't have
asked for any better father and son
finishing off yes yes chef i'm so happy
to know that me and my father can work
side by side without trying to kill each
other i mean it's a great feeling that's
what i always wanted
excellent hey what a difference they
look great beautiful
delicious yeah it is so delicious
yeah you did an excellent job today sam
i'm proud of us you know what i mean i
think overall my son did really really
good he pulled through so that shows me
a lot he made me realize that family
it's everything
and that's what we have with each other
this place is good at work bob
after an incredibly successful relaunch
the only thing left for gordon to repair
is the family we have come a long way
from the first minute i've walked in
here i saw a family that wasn't even
talking to each other
they were talking over each other and
nothing was sinking in
i asked all of you individually
to write a letter
and before i go
i want you to read the letter
kathy
to joe and sam
i see that our lives
and the way we exist and treat each
other is not acceptable any longer
we need real change before it's too late
joe i don't want to be a widow
please
try to trust in sam
you need to teach and support him you
need to let him make mistakes you need
to pull back
sam my beautiful son
[Music]
it's time to [ __ ] stand up
you know this has always been for you
and about you and your new life
don't be scared
it's time for you to shine
and start busting some ass
love ma and kathy
hold on my darling that was tough
sam you're not out of the woods
i thought maybe we didn't have time yeah
well
dear dad
this letter is coming straight from the
heart
i have always looked up to you
[Music]
dad i really truly only want you to be
proud of me
it feels like i am a big disappointment
to you because of my past immaturities i
really am sorry if i disappointed you
and even more sorry if i hurt you
i love you dad
all i want is to take this restaurant
over and let you relax
we is all we have and without each other
we are nothing
love your son sam
[Music]
amazing
and now the man
the reason why we're all here
take your time
to sam
hi sam
i am writing this few words
to let you know that this last couple
days
you made me realize how important you
are
to me
and i came to realize
that you are ready
i want you to take charge
finally i am really proud to have a son
like you
p.s
i never stopped loving you and i'll be
there for you no matter what happens
[Music]
love you then
you're an amazing family
you've just forgotten it
this is the closest i felt to my husband
and my son in a really long time
my father's saying that he loves me and
he's proud of me and he wants me to take
over it's everything i always wanted
it's my dream come true
chef ramsay brought back the love that
we had that we almost lost
and i'll never forget that
you are
the american dream
[Music]
good night good night
you